this week was terrible I hated it and
I'm never doing this again
I'm Abby I love coffee and I am giving
it up for a week because Business
Insider is making me and I drink coffee
every day multiple times a day
many different types cold hot and I'm
gonna give it up I guess I have no idea
how many cups of coffee I drink just
like a constant state of refilling my
mug at home it's harder because I have
to make it myself and I'm lazy so I'll
usually just have like one French press
cuz that's as much as I can deal with
I think the max is like several cold
fruit I can drink it cold much faster
which is very dangerous cuz I drink a
lot of coffee and then I talked twice as
fast and twice as much so I think I end
up lowering productivity of my team
overall my biggest challenges are gonna
be not drinking coffee I think it's
gonna be like getting into the swing of
things in the morning it's gonna be
tough so tomorrow will be my first day
without coffee
I am not excited for it pretty sad but
I'm going to be too tired to complain
about it today was my first day without
coffee honestly I forgot I didn't drink
coffee because I am very sick the
hardest part about not having coffee
today was around 3 p.m. when I realized
I still had to keep working but as the
week goes on and I get over this illness
I get angry or angry or about not
getting coffee I think it's gonna get
worse it is day 3 no coffee I'm not sick
anymore
and I'm feeling the caffeine loss right
after lunch is when I will usually go
and get my second or third coffee of the
day and I couldn't do that today
so I almost fell asleep in my desk I
just want it back right around like 2 or
3 p.m. is when I start to lose all focus
I feel significantly more tired too
in the afternoon here's one I want
coffee in general during the day I want
it right when I get to work it's part of
my routine desk kitchen desk and then I
want it immediately after lunch because
I eat too much I make myself tired that
way so we've got to combat it with
another cup of coffee the first one is
the easiest to skip because there's more
to do at the beginning of the day and so
I get distracted but the post lunch cups
are a necessity everybody around me is
drinking coffee the desk to my right as
a coffee she's got like a standing desk
and I'm not standing so the copy is
right at my eye level which is torture I
can smell it I can see it for whatever
reason people got monster-sized coffees
today I feel like it was to torture me
so I'm not looking forward to the next
few days without coffee I'm really
looking forward to being done the plan
was to get up around 9:00 and start
packing my apartment it's now 11:30 I
can't get over this tired hump I had a
cup of coffee okay so this week was
different than I thought it would be it
wasn't really like good things got
really hard and then it was fine
some days were harder than others the
days that I was home were hardest
because I didn't have anything to focus
on other than wanting coffee and then
the occasional afternoon at work mostly
because it disrupted my routine I was
more tired at times but I think the
biggest hurdle to get over was just not
having that as a part of my day
so I would get to work in the morning
not get my cup of coffee and then
immediately just be grumpy and then
finishing the day was also difficult
because I'm used to having that second
pick-me-up it was like I don't really
want to do this but I have to and
usually with my cup of coffee I'm like
alright time to work so I think was more
an attitude change than a Productivity
change I definitely had less headaches
this week almost none probably because I
was drinking more water and less
caffeine that being said
I still want the coffee people kept
hiding their coffee from me so I at
least know that I made other people
uncomfortable
throughout this while I was
uncomfortable I'm I don't want to cut
coffee out coffee and iron we're like
this and I'm not willing to lose that
relationship quite yet thank you it's
perfect this is the best kind of ice too